[Music]
here with the share don't be discouraged
oh I realize it's hard to take courage
[Music]
full of people you can lose sight of it
all this inside you can make it feel so
small but I see your true look at always
Michael Michael come on we've got a
shoot Michael listen
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
like a power ground
[Applause]
there's almost a spider-man link because
it starts off lights out like a power
outage lights out like a power
[Applause]
[Music]
I could kill the mist every time we kiss
just didn't know it down for like this
desert there's a flash-forward warning
will it will rain in the morning and
there'll be puddles in the bed I want
you to do it's a jungle inside your soul
somewhere deep inside at the end
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
survival your only goal plunge the jewel
inside say the name of the game
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you ready I'll star you can you keep
that rhythm crew pramana doesn't matter
what I do
oh I just keep doing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
never too early for a 10-4 Shirley Gary
Numan an influence for Walter of the
robot
[Applause]
I'm on the edge Laurie and I'm hanging
on and I'm hanging on a moment with you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
the man of the t-shirt the man of the
t-shirt know you're warm
Sam Liam Liam actually what's your name
geez are you Irish yeah oh this is
perfect
in case yeah okay so you'll be good at
this Oh fantastic
okay come down here come down here okay
so if they strike what do they like sort
of a like that if they do that you're
doing good
okay so this rustic opening oh look
she's very good look across at
everything
Oh Tom's in yeah okay so okay so you
ready okay we just got a little bit a
little blast of Irish dancing it's mean
look let's get more people if some of
you come out if all of you come out all
of you come out okay stand up comes you
step down step down everyone step down
okay there you go and if you put your
right foot out like that
okay good Liam and what's your name Emer
case the Inman case okay everyone ready
take it away
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
calimary
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
probably okay you've probably seen some
musicians before but get ready my friend
okay hit the track
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's the
[Music]
don't make fun let's take me all week
[Music]
you